because i have a few extra minutes with
you guys i am like asking some questions
sort of like to get to know you what tv
series would you love to guest star on
if it was still on game of thrones
i really i just think it's so cool i
love the whole concept and like i
watched it with my uh
family so like
i think it would be really cool and to
be on if it was still going that's a
good choice um i think i really would
love to be on mortal rings i am a huge
nerd for a lord of the rings
i would love to be like a an elf an
angelic alpha an angelic elf
you know
what's interesting is lord of the rings
is going to be going for five seasons
you have a chance and they're currently
filming that uh game of thrones uh
prequel series so you still have a
chance you know
on that
yeah we both still got it annie we can
do it possibly yeah
let's get it out there right by the way
you never know um what movie or movies
do you think you've seen the most
mean girls legally blonde clueless
ooh those are really good
um i've really i've watched a lord of
the rings i've watched it way too much
my family will have my room oh and harry
potter i forgot that my family binges
that like every few months
it becomes part of our family tradition
delays
lord of the rings and then um i've also
watched little miss sunshine a lot
um i really that's like a sweet one from
the movie uh what is your go-to karaoke
song
okay
so
i like valerie but i also thought of
another one blinding lights by the
weekends i feel like that's like
one yeah yeah
that's a good one um i i usually
generally go to i just want to dance um
by whitney houston
i'm not saying it can sound as good as
her but i love it it's such a good one
valerie
um written by these duchons and remade
by amy winehouse
and um
any disney song you can't go wrong yes
um jumping into actually uh the film um
i am curious for the two of you see you
get cast
how long did it take you to bring up
mean girls with uh your director since
he helmed mean girls
probably like first day
the first day we met in person like
before we started uh filming we had like
a just the
kind of um
cast like read-throughs and we taught i
just remember us talking a little bit
about that but i'd also worked with mark
before on another movie so this is my
second time working with him so we've
also already kind of talked about that a
lot
yeah um
same for us i think it brought it was
brought up immediately and just because
we were talking about references to that
movie as well and um but it was really
fun because on set
madison has did it and i i did it as
well the same day but we were we weren't
together at the same time when we did it
but like while we were filming we kind
of threw in a reference like i
referenced the plastics and he was
but i kept going and he was just like
he had a short time to film and i and i
did it i threw in a good for you annie i
know terrible and then madison i think
she like drove up in the car and was
like
get in
losers we're going shopping
because she pulls up under a little
convertible and she said that's great
uh i
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie so
for
for
soon to be fans of the film what do you
think uh they'd be surprised to learn
about the making of he's all that
should we tell the tanner story
annie do you want to tell the dinner
story yeah
um well we had a lot of fun in our set
like um
you know obviously we were being very
safe and being very careful this was
like
my first project in the pandemics it was
like a whole new way of filming um but
we still learned to have fun on set and
one thing that tanner did is there's
like um there were some dancers that
came on the set too and they were
wearing like little gold skirts and like
a gold bra and then one day tanner
decides to throw it on and we're like
and just like walked around on set and
we're just he just made everyone laugh
it was like a blast he's he's a he's a
goofball a big one
i had my 16th birthday on set which was
kind of fun but the very very last day
of filming like the movie was done
wrapped we were completely finished was
my actual birthday december 18th just if
you're curious but um
i had my like sweet 16 on set they like
surprised me with a cake someone kind of
ruined the surprise that's okay that's
okay um and they decorated my trailer so
like it was a grand old time for the
very very last
day of shooting
one of the things i learned about this
and people might not uh realize is uh
you shot the whole thing in like 23 days
which is a very
very tight production schedule for a
movie can you guys sort of talk about
making a film during covid with that
kind of shooting schedule
yeah it was tough
but the great thing the great thing
about our producers and our team and
especially mark waters is that they made
it so easy and made sure that we were
comfortable in doing it and so and
thankfully like thank god we had cast
that you know we got along with we all
knew how to have fun with each other and
it that just made it a million times
easier
yeah they're so professional with like
the whole kobit situation on set like
we'd get coded tested like every three
days like you check in the times you'd
have like wristbands
everybody has to wear masks like there's
a like guy like handing out masks like
you're not wearing
all the masks that was basically it the
whole time the whole time everyone
checks in
it was like a bit of a process but
you have to have that like special n95
mask yeah we were very worried honestly
because it was all of our first time
coming onto a set during the pandemic
but like they made us truly confident
and that was great and if we ever were
like too nervous about something like
they made us um
made sure that we were okay and they
took care of us really well
on that note i know there's going to be
a huge hit and i'm i'm sure of it you
guys have a fantastic day good luck with
the rest of your speed david thank you
you too